it's really been an interesting four
years from sean hannity he went from
already prominent right-wing
propagandist on fox news
really to a presidential insider i mean
a friend of donald trump's who
not so much recently but certainly
earlier on in his administration
hannity and trump often speaking on the
phone at night hannity was sometimes the
last person trump would speak to before
i i guess going to bed if that's
something donald trump does i don't know
he doesn't really seem
to do anything the way most of us do but
in any case um
sean hannity had really become an
insider sometimes traveling on uh
trump's uh helicopter or on air force
one he would do these
sycophantic softball interviews of trump
he would do sycophantic interviews of
kaylee mcinanny and many others
well sean hannity's ratings have
absolutely collapsed
since the election and eric bullert has
some great reporting on this
fox has actually been touting the latest
ratings numbers
as a big win for sean hannity and a lot
of publications fell for it and they put
together headlines that make it seem
like everything's going great for
hannity fox for example running an
article
on december 16th called sean hannity
tucker carlson
set records as fox news makes history
in 2020 cable news ratings but the truth
is there's been a massive decline
hannity's show falling into last place
for the 9 pm time slot among what's
called the key demographic the 25
to 54 demographic hannity
uh stuck in that last place for two
months now now
it is true that hannity still has a ton
of viewers in the aggregate
but the declines have been significant
and part of the reason
is people are abandoning fox for further
loony right wing content on newsmax
and on oan i've been teasing that later
this week we're going to look in detail
at an incredible
a focus group done by frank luntz with
trumpists and many of them
say fox's two left we're now with
newsmax and oan
so part of hannity's decline is that and
there's sort of good and bad there it's
good that fewer people are watching
hannity
but it's bad that lots of them are
watching something even crazier
instead others have abandoned
hannity and they started to in december
when it became clear that all of
hannity's commentary
about how trump is just about to
overturn the results
any day now this is the path mr mayor
rudy tell us what's the pa
once it became clear that wasn't going
to happen there were some i guess you
would call them deflated trumpets who
also
abandoned and it's also relevant to
think about the untold damage that
hannity did
throughout trump's presidency and one of
the reasons trump didn't face the same
fate as richard nixon
is there's a far more radical republican
party today
but another reason that trump didn't
face richard nixon's fate
is the right-wing media apparatus that's
so robust and powerful in the 21st
century that didn't exist
in the 1970s during richard nixon's
watergate scandal so
this is funny because i mean listen
it's funny because it's funny but it's
also
interesting because there are real
questions about what right-wing media
will look like during the next
for example two years the first two
years of joe biden's presidency and what
will be the lead up to the 2022
midterm elections something else that's
important
the size of the pie for radical
right-wing propaganda
is not getting any bigger right now so
at the beginning of trump's
uh candidacy and presidency trump
brought in
a lot of people who were never into
politics that grew the pie
for right-wing media people who never
paid attention to politics
started to fox was after being against
trump early in the republican primary of
2016
eventually supported trump and all of
this new audience people who never
watched the news before
were watching fox and newsmax was able
to get a little bit of it oan was able
to get a little bit of it
um but now as of 2020
the demand for radical right
disinformation propaganda
it's not growing in the aggregate which
means that fox news has to sort of split
its audience with oan and with newsmax
so right now
when newsmax grows some portion of that
growth is coming at the expense of fox
news
when oan grows some portion of that
growth is coming at the expense of fox
news
and it's more zero-sum than it's been in
a very long time it's not completely
zero-sum
but that's also a factor there will no
doubt
be an impact to fox news
from the reality that newsmax and oan
have bigger platforms than ever
who does fox news need to appeal to now
they already have
the oldest audience and those folks
will mostly stay with fox news rather
than going to oan
and newsmax the people that they need to
appeal to
are the 25 to 54 key demographic who
if you're 25 to 54 and you're watching
fox
and you're not pleased with them because
they're not right wing enough
and you bailed to fox to oan or newsmax
how does fox news win you back i don't
know the answer to that
i don't have an answer and quite frankly
i don't care it's for fox news to figure
out but it will be
interesting to follow now one other note
about the size of the pie
contrast this with independent left-wing
online media
independent left-wing online media has
been growing for two reasons over the
last several years
yes part of it is being in opposition to
trump the other part of it is that the
pie is growing and what i mean by that
is there are more and more people
who look for political content on
youtube so when i get a new viewer
i'm not likely to be taking it from tyt
or from sam cedar or others it's more
likely that someone is now
getting their analysis on youtube
instead of
from legacy corporate media that's a
very different dynamic
and i expect that that's going to
continue